[Musique]
je
pour
je suis autonome ans au maréchal ferrant
depuis 18 ans je suis situé sur granby
mon métier consiste à justement paraît
donc l'excédent de cornes sur les pieds
des chevaux donc qu'ils soient ferrer ou
pieds nus tout simplement et améliorer
aussi la locomotion des chevaux à
faire des soins s'il ya besoin également
quand il ya des pathologies des
problèmes des boiteries ou
oui
oh
ouais
donc on va dériver les clous et après on
va enlever le faire
pour justement pouvoir parer le pied et
puis travailler par la suite
on commence le déferrage
[Musique]
c'est comme si on tailler les ongles de
nîmes c'est exactement pareil c'est on
enlève tout l'excédent de caunes qui a
en trop qui a poussé cap avec la pince à
part et on vient on enlever l'excédent
de corne au niveau la hauteur
et même de la longueur
et à prendre un coup drap pour mettre à
plat plus à plat possible on renouvelle
la ferrure toutes les cinq six semaines
on peut aller jusqu'à 7 mais faut pas
les oblates là je reprends voir ce qu'on
peut appeler aussi c'est la pariétal
c'est pareil si on rappe l'excédent
[Musique]
voilà on va enlever les clous comment on
va remettre les mêmes faire
[Musique]
on les met dans la forme pour les
chauffer pour pouvoir les retravailler
devrait ajuster à la tournure s'il ya
besoin à nouveau
[Musique]
alors j'ai toutes les tailles de faire
on peut partir sur du c'ur du sein
même du plus petit qui est du 3 x 0
et du 3 x 0 pour des poneys après le 1
pour des chevaux classe i need lambda
on a un petit frère de course
sur les ti pur sang
et à peu près tous styles de fer
entre dufort rowling et dure aux lignes
un peu moins moins fort un peu plus
progressif et la re ligne un peu plus
agressif pour qu'on dit qu'on pourrait
faire un rolling au cheval c'est que on
travaille bien le biseau dû faire comme
ici pour que ça améliore le départ du
pays du cheval
[Musique]
nettoyez faire la brosse
on regarde s'il est bien à plat ça va
bien
si ça va pas en reste
[Musique]
alors on fait porter pour voir si tout
va bien on contrôle voir si la tournure
du fer est bien approprié aux pieds
d'uche oise est très important c'est
comme nous et humain va choisir une
paire de chaussures pour bien choisir
après on met à l'eau pour refroidir
donc ça c'est des plaques en plastique
très souple qui sont très bien donc je
lui ai mis les plaques en plastique a
surtout cheval parce qu'on avait un
petit problème au niveau de la sole et
des talons il avait fait une
une contusion sur les talons donc pour
venir le soulager j'ai préconisé des
plaques pour sa férule
[Musique]
ma plaque et bien chante raymond faire
aussi
[Musique]
voilà et d'essayer de mettre les clous
correctement
dans la paroisse et sans gêne et surtout
le cheval naipaul plus grande boîte si
on inclut on m'a placé
sortant paroisse justement pour après
river river les clous
[Musique]
on en rêvait le pays s'est serré les
coudes avec le faire et puis là
notamment avec les plaques et se refaire
une petite niche dans la paroisse pour
rabattre le clou dedans comment arriver
[Musique]
voilà même finir tiger on va le ramener
aux boks donc tout s'est bien passé on
vient toujours là comment il marche
[Musique]